andy i was kind of expecting you to have
like a man bun at this point like you're
looking so
fresh if i'm being real my wife gave me
a dope haircut
like she came correct quarantine looks
great on you
thank you i appreciate that and spending
time with my family it turns out is the
best
andy samberg is looking good and keeping
busy and quarantined
the comedian's pairing up with kristin
miliotti who you might remember as
leonardo dicaprio's first wife and the
wolf of wall street
in the feel-good hulu movie palm springs
it's one of those
infinite time-loop situations you might
heard about that i might have heard
about
i feel like one of my favorite parts
about this film was that like it's about
having to be okay with yourself and that
you can't actually escape yourself
the second you fall asleep it all just
goes back to the start
in the romantic comedy andy and kristen
relive the same day over and over again
it's streaming today but will also be
released in several drive-in theaters
across the country
you get to be all cozy in your car you
bring your snacks like you're outside
it's great there's like a decent chance
that brad pitt is living in a trailer
behind the screen
look what i got for you that's right
that's what i heard oh my god
goldie hawn's daughter-in-law meredith
hagner and riverdale star camila mendes
round out this cast
i think what's beautiful about this
movie is you have an opportunity to
laugh but also it does
make you think kind of deeply about what
matters yeah i'd say the same thing
when i think we are faced with the
question of what is
the meaning of life i think the closest
answer we have
is love and people connecting with
people
you